it's hard to argue against the
possibility that all of us are not just
the creation of some kid in a parent's
basement I think most likely this is
just about probability there are many
many simulations
what's that believe nation it's Evan I
believe in you and this channel is
designed to be a part of your daily
success routine so today we're going to
talk about are we living in a simulation
and we're going to Neil deGrasse Tyson
and Elon Musk for answers also if you
want to know what Elon Musk and other
successful entrepreneurs have to say
about building unstoppable confidence
check out my 250 for confidence series
where every day for the next 254 days I
will send you a morning video for free
to help you build your confidence the
link to join is a description below
there are times when something is
important enough you believe in it
enough that you do it in spite of the
fear are we living in simulation I find
it hard to argue against that
possibility meaning meaning you look at
our computing power today and you say I
have the power to program a world inside
of a computer
well imagine in the future where you
have even more power than that and you
can create characters that have for
example free will or their own
perception of free will so this is a
world and I program in the laws that
govern that world that world will have
its own laws of physics and chemistry
and biology now you're a character in
that world and you think you have free
will and say I want to invent a computer
so you do hey I want to create a world
in my computer and then that world
creates a world in its computer and then
you have simulations all the way down so
now you lay out all these universes and
throw a dart which of these universes
are you most likely to hit the original
one that started it or the countless
simulations the dotter simulations that
unfolded there after you're gonna hit a
simp you're going to hit one of the
simulations so statistically based on
that argument which first appeared by a
philosopher from Oxford named Nick
Bostrom back in the 1990s right when
computers were becoming real enough to
think this through
it's it's hard to argue against the
possibility that all of us are not just
the creation of some kid in a parent's
basement programming up a world for
their own entertainment and then every
time something weird happens in the
world some disruptive leader takes
charge and I wonder if that programmers
just got bored and had to stir the pot
so it's throw somebody in there just to
just for their own entertainment for me
that's some of the best evidence we live
in a simulation because this happens
every time there's peace and tranquility
in the world but if it's true what can
we do about it if like the Truman movie
other was that we're in yeah well he can
try to escape by going in the Truman
movie to go through the barrier yeah but
yeah if you're if you were programmed by
somebody yeah you know there's nothing
you can so what difference does it make
if I'm programmed by someone I guess is
I don't know it I guess it doesn't make
any difference at all this could be some
simulation it could do you entertain
that well the argument for the
simulation I think is quite strong
because if you assume any improvements
at all over time any improvement 1% 0.1%
just extend the time frame make it a
thousand years a million years the
universe is 13.8 billion years old or
what a civilization if you count it if
you're very generous civilization is
maybe seven or eight thousand years old
if you count it from the first writing
this is nothing this is nothing so if
you assume any rate of improvement at
all then games will be indistinguishable
from reality or civilization will end
one of those two things will occur
although we are most likely in a
simulation I think most likely this is
just about probability there are many
many simulations these simulations are
we might as well call them reality or
you could call them multiverse these
simulations you believe are created like
someone has man if they're running on
the substrate so that substrate is
probably boring boring mm-hmm how so
well when we create a simulation like a
game or a movie
it's the distillation of what's
interesting about life you know I get it
takes take a year to shoot an action
movie and then that's all distilled down
into two or three hours so let me tell
you if you see an action movie being
filmed
friggin it's boring super boring it
takes there's like lots of takes so
everything is in a green screen looks
pretty goofy doesn't look cool but once
you add the cgi and have great editing
it's amazing so I think most likely if
we're a simulation it's really boring
outside the simulation because why would
you make a simulation that's boring it
makes simulation way more interesting
the basic reality that is if this right
now is a simulation yes and ultimately
inevitably we're if as long as we don't
die or get hit by a meteor we're going
to create some sort of simulation if we
continue on the same technological path
where we're on right now yes but we
might not be there yet
so it might not be a simulation here but
it most likely is you feel other places
this notion of place or where is is a
fraud yes when you're in the and that's
in that virtual reality which is only
gonna get better where are you where are
you really right you aren't anywhere
well where is in the computer anyway I
don't want to sound like like thanks for
to dark because I think like you kind of
have to be optimistic about the future
there's no
point in being pessimistic it's just too
negative does this house it doesn't help
you know I think you want to be I mean
my theory is like you'd rather be
optimistic I think it rod I'd rather be
optimistic and wrong than pessimistic
and right right at least or on that side
right yeah is if you're pessimistic it's
going to be miserable yeah yeah nobody
wants to be around you anyway if it's
the end of the world you're like I've
told you bro yeah the world ending you
know it is greatest for all I mean enjoy
the journey right if you really want to
get morose I mean it is what it is for
all of us anyway we were all gonna go
unless some something changes yeah you
know I mean ultimately you know even if
we just sort of existed as humans
forever we'd be we'd still eventually
that'd be like the heat death of the
universe right as well Ian years from
now right now if we get it past the Sun
if we hadn't got away past the Sun
running out of juice eventually it's
gonna end it's just a session of when
right so it really it's all about the
journey hmm or transcendence from
whatever we are now into something that
doesn't worry about death the universe
as we know it will dissipate into a fine
mist of cold nothingness eventually and
then someone's gonna bottle it and put a
fragrance to it sell it to French people
in another dimension it's just a very
long time yeah I think it's really just
about how can we make it last longer so
admittedly this is not something that I
spend any of my time thinking about I'm
focused on my mission what I'm doing
making videos for you guys trying to
solve the world's biggest problem but I
want to know what do you think
are we in bass reality is this a
simulation what are your thoughts on
what Elon and Neil said I'd love to hear
from you leave your thoughts in the
comments below
one was long yeah the most important
work ever if you had to think of one
word that's most important to you or
that sums you Apple
that would be collect a little beacon if
you want to know what Elon Musk thinks
about human cyborgs and AI check out the
video right next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there
so some degree we are already a sidewall
over time I think we'll probably see a
closer merger of biological intelligence